[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
or we talk about whatever I'm trying to
help you but I do it every time you got
me some really nice flowers so say
whatever you want
hey tip how was your day are you big
you're the bass fired out of nowhere
treasure creep on the mic just to get a
couple words in you up guys there's
always like that he's doing the [ __ ]
[ __ ] would you like me thumbs oh I love
them but where do they go though what do
you mean yeah
they stayed in that era yeah we did it
it's only survived by by greaser Mexican
guys you know that company your eye
I got ear booger so she she tries to
blow it out of my ear you have like a
whole bunch of dandruff right here and
all stop staring at it and I just had to
like get rid of it move on it's eczema
it's not Bandra well I saw flakes and I
was staring at it so I wanted to thank
you she gave you a [ __ ] ah we just
saw it rose you guys saw her get [ __ ]
little I'm like why can't the guys just
dude thank you you pictured a guy gonna
do that I have a question remember back
in like the 60s and [ __ ] when they would
like I don't I wasn't there
right uh you should when they would blow
in the person's ear yeah yeah yeah I
also saw it in an episode of Fresh
Prince of bel-air what does that do
again I don't know that supposed to be
like it's some sexy [ __ ] yeah because I
think sister's name
the little girl oh yeah I know she blew
in his in the guy's ear and then we'll
saw it
I think sweet nothings well the one that
I heard in elementary school was like
give me your hand
oh this thing yeah actually wrong in
would you be like this and then you kind
of like this you know it all it's like
are you telling them that you want to
[ __ ] them yeah I hated that [ __ ]
touch yeah no one ever did something
yeah yeah we were done like get the [ __ ]
that's the secret [ __ ] signal yeah no
wonder that's me
no bloom on the ear neither oh my ear
but I just was that I never happened to
me hoping somebody in here somebody blew
my ear
really oh it's not really a belonging
like hardcore like a [ __ ] hurricane
blow but it's just like when you kiss
someone on their ear you kind of breathe
into it
mm-hmm oh yeah I do that yeah maybe
that's it but not like I think used to
ear boogers deeper into the canal right
now good luck getting those out [ __ ] I
have to see it you know how like
everything sounds much louder like why
you're [ __ ] someone's by your ear
right you don't need that sound that
sound like what like that whistling you
know that whistling that someone's
breathing what is louder
you've seen is quieter like it's
without the recorder do you guys are
usually loud no that's me you're loud
uh I heard ladies are louder because
they're telling the other tribe like
like yo I'll give it like biologically
yes yeah she's telling the other dudes
like Bart's doing me over here am i yeah
so Joe knows in the other tent like yeah
yeah yeah that girl gets it I think so I
don't know like they want to get it
coming [ __ ] try to kiss Torian is
just some [ __ ] I heard to keep other
females away yo mate oh maybe maybe I'm
a little twisted but I was like tell the
other dudes like yeah I'm fertile we're
receiving it so they're basically
telling the other guys that this guy
gives you food I just build up the game
or something I run a huge article the
other day to uh we're talking I was
talking with my chat on twitch about uh
guys with your chat message hat hello
guys faking orgasms and I was like I
don't get that one I don't know how guys
you mean up playing it like they come
and go no fake thankful face like no no
and then I had I had some boys talking
to me kind of podcast outs with my
homies I'm not gonna mention any names
but it's people you know you can't fake
it and they mentioned they mentioned
faking it and faked it they said condom
or or like whatever and you just fake it
I was like I don't get why and I was
like brought you ask him why um so my
friend and then they throw away the
condom oh I blew so hard so so the
article had like six different examples
that they interviewed he was like men's
health or some [ __ ] you know I'm
just googling things to be silly and so
one of them was like the guy I didn't
know it and uh that he was gay but then
he found out like in that moment he had
a girlfriend he's like in his 20s he
found out he's like yeah I just couldn't
education no no no oh it's really good
and he does that because you yeah wait
so he could never come with a woman yeah
another one was like whistle so he's
having sex and he's like man I wish her
legs were hairy kinda what I heard I
heard the longer the guy lasts the more
get curious they are gay curious yeah
cuz then that means they're not that
turned on but if you come really faster
extremely that's what I was trying to
tell my buddy he's like he's like I had
to fake it I was in a relationship for
like two years I was like two years
isn't that long bro that's like I'm so
horny like [ __ ] is killer like you make
a movie called gone in 60 seconds gone
in 30 second well 30 seconds oh I don't
know so my buddy yeah his excuse was a
that it was in a relationship and he
just used that guy was tired I was like
you sound like a 45 year old woman like
shut the [ __ ] up dude I've never once
experienced that a whiskey-dick one I
forgot the other I've heard of whiskey
dick is I get it just go it just goes
away right yeah I think you just can't
get it I would just keep pounding until
it comes out something's gonna happen
guys before they're like I just I can't
you know cuz we spent like an hour and I
just can't I drink too much I'm like oh
it's okay it's cool like we'll try it in
the morning like why do you have to fake
I guess for men it's strange to fake it
for women I get cuz you're just like oh
I don't wanna hurt his ego yeah I think
that's [ __ ] up choices to be honest
right maybe that's the same for the
girls I think they're gonna hurt the
girl's feelings if they don't they're
considerate men gentlemen I'm just
trying to not just trying to none of the
kids are gonna be able to wear this in
school everyone has a bad word that's
why like Spencer t-shirt thank your
novelty or just say I'm just trying to
and then show like I'm not like an apron
or something okay still can't wear that
[ __ ] in school really why would they
don't sexual innuendo maybe in college
mmm maybe if the whole thing is emojis
teachers won't be able to figure out
what no but anyway that's interesting I
didn't know a whole bunch of guys not a
whole bunch yeah I didn't know that
period why didn't either
yeah
the first time I ever heard of that was
when I watched 40 days 40 nights with
Josh Hartnett oh I used to love him yeah
whatever happened to that guy I know
what happened he go oh yeah like she
went to try to look for something that
looked like come to put in the condom
cuz the girl wanted to see it for some
reason
oh but he couldn't have sex or something
he couldn't no it's not that you
couldn't have sex he just couldn't come
you look for coming that's what I'll
tell you how I feel like I probably had
a look for for what [ __ ] Jake a skit
or something Google fake comment no I
just had to get creative with a bunch of
[ __ ] like Elmer's glue Elmer's glue so
there was this one skit that they wrote
where they're like crying in a movie
theater and I had to mimic like real
tears for like a [ __ ] for our shoot
you know so I had to like experiment
with a lot of different [ __ ] and I ended
up putting glue in their eyes because it
looked like glue just got it's dripping
down slow yeah so like I feel I feel
like I had to like sit there and
experiment with comfort you say come in
porn all the time oh really yeah porn
starts with what I don't know what they
use but for sure they use more star that
would hurt the ego if I'm like yo my job
is [ __ ] like this is what I do you
know and then like you come in here the
state change you just run out of come
now if my job is coming I'm never
running out of comb if I'm gonna I don't
know man well that's why I'm not a porn
star but if I don't think that's why
you're not a point oh that's why that's
the one monogamy what do you think it is
is porn star material cuz it let's say
you came three times that day in the Sun
they don't come afford yeah there's your
ran out not if I'm a porn star what are
you gonna tell Michael Jordan took 20
shots he's not twenty one guy lives
I know if you're a porn if this is you
put your stamp on the world saying this
is what I do for a profession you better
is Joe gonna run out of goddamn fair man
your honor
yeah no no Joe is funny forever I just
know cuz I jacked off so much that my
[ __ ] can't come was like doing the
moves of coming and nothing came out
there's like dry heaving yeah you had
phantom come that I've seen I think the
guys are always like tapped out like the
come is like three [ __ ] four little
drops like majority of scene there's
never like any company he's always like
oh yeah and it's like four little drops
on like you had like three shoots before
that's why we have to fake come women
judges like that yeah but some yeah I
don't know some of it is like they use
fake come in porn for sure photo I like
um shots probably come compilations um I
mean obviously if it's coming out of Oh
unless it's like there's like the guys
holding his dick and he's jacking off
and then maybe there's a little straw on
the side and installed like you
gives him a signal so while he's coming
the other guy's like there's a really
long straw all right the guys holding
the straw and his buddies behind up and
he's like low budget okay low budget
that's plenty to do baking for it
yeah that sounds funny but we [ __ ]
did another skit where I had to piss on
myself and that was literally the
technique well he has a tube right no it
was a water bottle with the [ __ ] tube
and someone was squeezing and I was
pissing on my did you just pee on
yourself
I was tapped up
I'm a typical Dornan's gotta be that's
why I don't do it anymore
she's not a professional peer I don't
act anymore I'm done acting it was a
skill where girls got wet right that one
oh because of the the it was role
reversal right where guys get a bonus
get a boner working out or someone that
it was pink
those kids are good no man no cuz then
we went to a classroom and you've there
like a puddle all right I was wet that
whole day and not the business yeah I
was wet that hold it is is being wet
uncomfortable ah what does it just dry
up later no again I mean it's wet when
you're like oopsy-daisy I got turned on
no it's not just boys butters can be
uncomfortable I've had soaking drawers
damn I got a tank
chalo drop-lid but I've never had like a
full you know like the square the second
square inside the tank like I've never
had that like yeah I've even had to go
through peds PMI so she gets horny crazy
she gets horny telling you it was like
wetness or like Western no witness like
she's not used affection I've never had
a yeast infection but yeah it's that
dress it's this [ __ ] that way you get
wet with four clear shoes you have the
clear shape a good [ __ ]
she stays hydrated [ __ ] laughs sounds
like a dick that can't come it sounds
like my [ __ ] dry heaving come
wait till you tell me this charge can
only happen when you have a yeast
infection no no no oh my god you have
double eyelids look at it put it over no
no I just thought of it as a joke
because then you get discharged when you
have you look better with this we have a
different set of eyes like I just
changed got smaller starts blinking
that's like a goddamn alien it looks
really cool I wish you have those what
those eyes those [ __ ] is mystique
habit
oh maybe it is [ __ ] shape of water
creature they stole that that's a weird
[ __ ] movie it's a weird [ __ ] movie
and - that's the exact same character
from [ __ ] Hellboy they totally copied
our mood y'all [ __ ] reptile just a
regular water we took it like a human
tau which what human like a sex like
mystique
I'm good who's the original mystique
famous film yeah if that's my mystique
I'd [ __ ] the lizard it was fine dude we
went to Hollywood so Hollywood Boulevard
host like the whole strip or whatever
they closed off that street and people
just come in costumes and it gets wild
and people get really creative it was
this girl that dress just like mystique
and she was fine I was like god damn so
she was like pretty much naked and she
had the whole blue thing and I was like
is it like scales Honda or an avatar the
blue avatar yeah I'd [ __ ] her to us I
wanted a [ __ ] what and I didn't know
what [ __ ] was but I was very
attracted to the Beast you got with
reality that's more bestiality that's
like a big old wolf I mean he was fun
he's beat yeah
oh it that'd be all I thought about
beats the blue the blue guy he was
pretty hot too and they specially put
the glasses on I was like oh if smart
Beast is bees I always thought he was a
lion but he's not he's gonna move in
Beauty and the Beast yeah he's like a
buffalo right the wolf uh-oh I think
you're right below yeah he's got some
little baby ones and like baby yeah
they're like baby's ears on this big-ass
body I get it in rest the Beast smell
was [ __ ] hot
and then the prints from the head of a
buffalo the brow of a gorilla test so a
wild boar legs and Tails um that's what
[ __ ] look there that's just what they
sing isn't it isn't that in the song
[ __ ] what's the name Gaston swear you
those are not what's fine as [ __ ] - you
know he was fine I think I've always
just liked [ __ ] beatnik meaty
things like football players thanks Eric
from Ariel like he was hot - he was a
little smaller friend a little metroís a
little smaller but none of the Disney
Princesses made the morning really Ariel
was fine cartoons jasmine is kind of
[ __ ] oh I like cartoons
with my [ __ ] oh what's it what's uh
anime porn uh and tire yeah you and the
hand time educate Ross I'm good teach me
teach me teach me do you want dude do
you watch or read comics no not at all
not wrong is that the only way I could
make it happen with some hentai hint
okay
the anti gets really weird yeah a
tentacle porn right yeah we talked about
hentai a lot no but it makes you horny i
watch hand side before it I got ya cuz
they're the most similar to human then
American cartoon I think cuz I saw one
with the tentacles and I got horny no
cuz they get to zoom in on things like I
remember the scene where I was like this
chick she's in like a schoolgirl outfit
and I think that tentacle thing like had
like all these pentacle uh like it was a
mechanical tentacles so a trap dude
she's like oh I'll helpless and then I
guess as she gets helpless her boobs
start shaking and gets and then so you
don't anime anime like things they shake
like this yeah and then it zoomed into
her buttons and her buttons were like
dink
I don't like tentacle porn but it's a
very popular category do you guys ever
watch it together [ __ ] no she likes gay
porn go get the sword fight you boy like
all kinds of porn
you just saw the pretty weird pointy
lights really weird [ __ ] - I'm so [ __ ]
she likes guys having sex that's not
that great but sex guy but sex yeah
that's not bad like - doesn't said it's
bad I'm just asking yes
I don't judge anyone I want to know what
Bart was talking about because I'm gonna
react okay so my shits are weird because
I'm so particular about the personal so
the girls have to have like a perfect
[ __ ] they have to have like that's not
a super pink bottle so anytime I see any
huge butthole they just have to look
unreal perfect right kinda Navy abajo
it's hard to find it is so that's why I
quote a weird [ __ ] so then because I
can't find people that turn me on enough
then I just go for latex so all I feel
latex yeah so there's this all like that
like like latex latex jack balls in June
that's [ __ ] hot latex or loosie
loosie latex or some [ __ ] like that
latex Lucy don't act like you don't know
you don't forgot the order but that's
the name I just don't know the order
she's fine
cuz her tits are huge her waist is tiny
her ass is fat but she's a full eight
you mean like the mass and all you see
is a mouth is she got I just got like a
dog leash I know she's not on solid she
should've been hung by her skin Nash
nothing huh but like nothing's pink well
hot because it's so unrealistic and the
proportions are perfect that I'm like
good I don't have to see your dark
pothole or whatever
she [ __ ] dude yeah they [ __ ] her or
whatever or there's two people in latex
and I don't get to ever see their face
so then I'm always like that's pretty
hot I don't yeah I don't think I could
do that one but y'all look at me weird
for watching gay porn back yeah I'm just
too picky dude I don't watch it every
time but I happen to enjoy putting that
out there it's not everyday thing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]